E = mc2, energy is equal to mass times the
speed of light squared.
We’ve demonstrated this to dramatic effect
with nuclear bombs, converting a little mass
into a lot of energy, but we’ve never done
it the other way around and turned energy
into mass.
At least we haven’t done it… yet.
When you think high energy, where does your
mind go?
That’s right, to Trace.
But after that, probably lasers.
And lasers are getting extremely powerful.
The current record-holding laser resides in
China, at the Shanghai Superintense Ultrafast
Laser Facility.
In 2016 it set the bar at 5.3 million billion
Watts of power, or 5.3 Petawatts.
Even though that’s a lot of power, it doesn’t
last very long.
Power is energy over time, so there are two
ways to make these super powerful lasers.
Scientists can just up the energy, but certain
components like the amplifiers can’t handle
more energy unless they’re impractically
large.
One laser in the US uses 1.8 megajoules to
produce about one petawatt and it’s the
size of a 10 story building.
The other approach to upping the power is
by packing that energy into a very short amount
of time.
The laser in Shanghai fires for just a few
quadrillionths of a second.
In that tiny timespan, the laser produces
about 500 times the power of all the world’s
electrical grids combined, while being small
enough to fit on a tabletop.
And yet it’s still not enough.
Chinese scientists are upgrading the facility
with the goal of hitting 10 petawatts by the
end of the year.
And they’re hoping to build another laser
capable of pumping out 100 petawatts by 2023,
if the Chinese government approves the roughly
100 million dollar price tag.
China might have a compelling reason for footing
the bill though: at these powers levels scientists
can achieve new and mind-bending things, like
plucking electrons from an empty vacuum.
Well… when I say empty, it really isn’t,
at least according to the theory of quantum
electrodynamics.
Because the quantum world is a silly place,
for the briefest of moments, electrons and
their antimatter evil twins, positrons, flicker
into existence before their opposite charges
draw them together and poof!
They’re gone again.
But a 100 petawatt laser beam focused down
to just 3 micrometers across should create
an electric field so intense as to keep the
electron and positron separate.
The energy from the laser would also shake
the electron and positron enough that they
give off gamma rays that create more electron
positron pairs and radiation we’ll be able
to detect.
A chain reaction that creates matter from
energy.
Of course we’re still an order of magnitude
shy of this kind of power, but after we overcome
the technical hurdles we’ll be able to try
our hand at using E = mc2 for creation rather
than destruction.
Special thanks to Domain dot com for sponsoring
this episode of Seeker!
Domain dot com is awesome, affordable, reliable,
and have all the tools you need to build a
new website.
They can fulfill all your website needs.
They offer dot com and dot net domain names,
and intuitive website builders.
They have over three hundred domain extensions
to fit your needs, from dot club to dot space,
dot pizza!
Take that first step in creating an identity
online and visit domain dot com.
For more news about lasers, subscribe!
We make videos about them all the time, like
this one about how scientists are using diamonds
to combine laser beams a la the death star.
Super powerful lasers can have more uses than
pulling electrons from thin air.
Scientists are exploring how they might be
used to treat cancer or build smaller particle
accelerators.
That’s all for now, I’ll see you next
time on Seeker.